[Music]
hi
mystery recapped here today i am going
to explain a sci-fi drama film called
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
[Music]
in the near future social media has
become a subject of world dominance and
social media celebrities have an immense
influence on our culture the commoners
follow them blindly and buy whatever
product they endorse and consume such
media influencers sell their lives on
the internet to a level that they have
no privacy their main motto is to not
lose followers and they are ready to go
to extreme lengths to achieve that one
such influencer is a young woman named x
x lives in a tiny futuristic room that
serves as her workplace lounging area
and her bedroom so far this is sounding
terrifyingly familiar at the beginning
of the movie she is in front of a
futuristic ai computer that displays her
followers reacting to her content they
come and go so quickly that x has to
reply to more than 50 interactions per
minute an ai personnel named taya helps
her by posting the comments on her
command and walking her through the
activities of the day every few minutes
tia reminds ex to upload a status most
of the time x throws in some
inspirational quotes which get more than
100 million likes each in her recent
status she advises her followers to know
and love what they're doing for success
that status alone gets 104 million likes
taya tells x when to stop working for
the day it is clear that x doesn't have
much control over her life but she is
too busy counting her followers to
notice her daily progress is displayed
on the screen which says that she has
gained more than a million followers in
just one day making her follower count
closer to hitting a billion she was
mentioned 27 million times per minute
she received 4 billion likes and 19
million dislikes and her annual
subscriber revenue is a whopping nine
and a half trillion dollars
adjusted for inflation this is probably
just enough to pay rent
the computer finally shuts off and she
breathes a sigh of relief taya again
asks her for a status update and she
recites yet another motivational quote
more than 100 million people like the
update instantly looks like x is using
bots even after getting off the computer
x is still working there is a cluster of
cameras fitted on the ceiling of her
room that live streams her life to
millions of special subscribers at all
times people pay millions of dollars to
watch her change clothes sleep read her
emails and so on her work desk
automatically slides underground and her
bed emerges from the floor indicating it
is time to sleep she takes off her
clothes to go to bed when taya announces
that there are 204 million subscribers
currently watching the following morning
x wakes up to gentle rain patting on her
window she gets up and immediately
submits her early morning status on
tia's request x then takes a picture of
herself edits it heavily and posts it on
the internet when she gets off the bed
she is completely naked her body is
censored to some of the followers who
are told to upgrade their subscription
to get the full view when it's time for
her to shower a shower room
automatically arises in a corner even in
the shower 300 million premium
subscribers are allowed to watch she
takes a picture with her body wash which
increases its sales by a lot however x's
subscriber count goes downhill because
of her next status in which she implies
that it is impossible to argue with
women x quickly asks tia to take a
picture of her body while showering and
posts it to all of her followers this
doubles the count of her new subscribers
and her status recovers again x then
requests her followers to vote for her
on famous.com to make her the greatest
influencer of all time along with the
request she attaches a nude picture of
herself when it is time for her to get
ready for the day the room creates an
automated wardrobe for her she simply
asks the ai for a blue dress the command
triggers a drone who flies around x and
creates a tailor-fitted dress according
to her wish it also chooses appropriate
accessories for her and makes her look
pretty for the followers because of her
influence the sales of the blue dress
increase exponentially as she is taking
pictures for the tenth time this morning
she receives her mail on peeking through
the looking hole she sees an empty
hallway outside it is time for her to
check into work so she ignores the mail
for the time being suddenly her computer
screen goes black and a message saying
do you question flashes instead of the
comments a few seconds later the screen
goes back to normal so x doesn't think
much of it but without her noticing an
envelope that she just received in the
mail starts glowing as x goes through
the day she eats all her meals in front
of the computer promoting them for the
followers some hours later taya
announces that it is x's time to relax
she gets only a 10 minute break
throughout the day for the break she can
choose a program from their computerized
vacationing subscription she gets to
choose to go to a virtual beach party
spa and others while shuffling through
the options she gets a paper cut from
the envelope on her hand she doesn't
think much of it and continues shuffling
the beach seems a viable option but the
people there are her fans who cannot
stop gushing over her presence so she
skips them what she doesn't notice is a
strange man being formed on his own in
the background moments later she stops
to watch a firework display and is
enjoying it until the man from the beach
starts walking towards her she feels
uncomfortable and skips again but the
man is also present in the next program
he asks her if she questions her life or
just goes along with it x is too scared
to understand what he means she retreats
as the man crosses the barrier and
somehow enters her room he raises his
hands to touch her and the contact gives
rise to sparks of electricity the man
disappears right afterwards but he has
provided x with the ability to
understand her reality
moments later she composes herself and
opens the envelope for the first time
inside is a tablet that says question
everything when she turns it around the
tablet asks her if her cage exists she
tries to comprehend what it means and
realizes that she has never been out of
her room which might mean that it is her
cage she walks up to her door and leans
down on it but because of her earlier
interaction with the guy the stimulation
doesn't work on her and she falls to the
other side the horrifying truth of her
life is then revealed to x it turns out
that she is being used as a worker by a
multi-billion dollar influencer company
that keeps them trapped in a tiny box in
a factory
she has been trapped and has been lied
to about her life similar to her the
company cages thousands of influencers
and uses them for their own good x
quickly runs back to her room and looks
at the tablet again taya announces that
her break time is over so she will have
to update her status soon when x doesn't
answer taya warns her of the
consequences if she doesn't update her
status x can no longer differentiate
between the illusions and reality around
her just then the rain outside her
window begins to glitch tia informs her
that failing to update her status is a
violation of the celebrity franchise
handbook having had enough of the lies x
asks tia if she is in a cage taeya
mistakes x's question as a status update
and claims that a question is an invalid
status according to the handbook axe yet
again asks her if she's in a cage
instead of answering the machine replies
that all of her subscribers have left
the room and she has no followers now x
quickly tries to recover and takes her
clothes off to show off her body and
regain her followers but the strategy
doesn't work this time she desperately
tries to take a seductive picture but
taya stops answering following that
three men enter the room and drag x
outside as she retaliates when she wakes
up x is in a hospital bed being taken
care of by a machine the door opens and
two doctors enter the room dr mitchell
is happy because x is her last eval of
the day they look at her report and find
out that x's real name is alexandra they
ask ex for status but she takes her time
to reply because of the lag they
diagnosed that her speech and response
time are lagging she had been working
for 22 hours and the last sleep she had
was around four hours the doctors
believe that her sleep cycle is the root
of the problem as they discuss this x
doesn't respond with anything she has a
hard time grasping reality all of a
sudden she claims that she has 800
million subscribers but the doctor
informs her they are all gone they call
her old and believe that she is no
longer of service to the company x
starts to freak out because her follower
count is the only thing she cared about
until now she insists that she is loved
by her fans however the doctors declare
that it is her time to retire now the
second doctor gil finally shows his face
and reveals that he is the guy who met x
earlier in her room he calms a frantic x
and leaves the room before leaving dr
mitchell comments about the increasing
number of crasher cases in the
influencers one can assume that dr gill
doesn't agree with the company's values
and is rescuing the influencers one
after another in the final scene a
screen appears before x welcoming her to
the internet as a consumer subscribe for
more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching